welcome to this video playing Batgirl
okay wgm bad girl and not what I saw I
edition she's actually quite well-known
she did some of the live broadcasts in
recent years and from Chaz events mostly
in Russia let's see mm-hmm incorrect
Kings inion I'm playing a bit of the
classical have looked at some lines I
mean not in huge detail but look at some
stuff okay taking that said and it's a
relatively new line I mean yeah it is
known for years but only in none recent
times it has become more popular yeah
like is going for f5 here this one
possibility at least yeah or this one I
think they play look T 1 here look ad
one
i'm not mistaken check
yeah let's tick tick with that yeah in
general like some player is fairly
straightforward he or she in the San
just case has some active pieces so hmm
why is it possible can take care f5
right I should always be a little
something unless I'm overlooking a
tactic which might be happening it's
their tactic i don't know otherwise why
do definitely have some some positional
advantage you are taking and Bishop
reform is a slight edge for wider
definitely White has done more compact
pawn structure here this sir in the
situation and also blacks king is
slightly exposed 95 Queen c3 is a
typical idea this is nothing great for
white but black has to suffer here
because of as mentioned the structural
deficits let's see b3 and probably I
cannot do without them anyway nighty for
Queen c3 would also be nice going for
that I'm not sure if she may be needed
to do something about 94 she totally
didn't react to it I'm not sure what
black should have done but this looks a
bit uncomfortable ok so here I'm going
to introduce the idea night c 5 online
five okay I can give this check into g8
what directly can also wait wait wait
wait check and take on see if I of
course after i can take on c5
that's the pain sorry that's the big
issue here winning the pawn and in the
process also get a good good structure
here blocking the a pond um interesting
she's offering a queen trade that's a
bit difficult to not do that yeah but
now where is the night going that's an
interesting question actually the move a
form is really a bit of an annoyance
let's block it for a moment I have the
idea c5 as well yeah yeah I can a
thought I can go back and now
threatening 95 so yeah okay she had to
do something about that rookie seven
maybe yes on a four and now have before
so the move a four is not particularly
dangerous at least I thought maybe a
three root beer but there is no there is
no substantial counter player thing okay
if I go b5 I think she has to go to be
seven the check
yeah and the checkers Czech is pretty
good
okay I didn't really think about that
move but it's not not a big deal i get
to e7 now anyway yeah okay this is a
completely winning endgame doing pin I
can go all the way to d4 now i have c 5
let's let's check c5 king e 5 92 to d4
and that's it yeah okay our efforts
check maybe f4 check is even easier yeah
this is probably even easier it's both
as it's pretty good the dead piece on
aid check check ok so now c6 asking this
Bishop a very embarrassing question
black resigns yeah that I really don't
know they're the opening theory here I
just think that when I got to this this
is a this is a comfortable position for
white at least it is some may be nothing
special in particular but whenever we
look at this it's pretty clear that i
always have ideas like this or this for
the night blacks bishop cannot cover
both squares and this is simply not a
very good structure it is always a
little bit weak so I have my doubts here
that black has equalized the computer is
giving white 0.7 which is quite a lot
actually I would've thought that was
precise play em should be possible to
keep it within smaller margins but ok
the computer wants to defend like that
kingi 8 b 3 which is maybe not essential
but
yeah probably hard to not play it in the
long run and then the compounds to put
the bishop on c6 which is an interesting
idea at least in this way and say here
intending f5 now this is a very check
very ugly position this is the computers
main lines 0.7 now here black is
suffering the king is just insecure this
is an additional problem of the
structure here the king is just without
the f porn is just more exposed so those
little things they add up and make some
black make some and blacks life a little
bit a little bit difficult okay that was
interesting thanks for watching